un 4 de julio opacado por la violencia
en Estados Unidos en las horas previas a
las habituales festividades que marcaban
el 247 aniversario desde la
independencia estadounidense nuevos
tiroteos masivos volvieron a poner en
Jaque al país norteamericano un ataque
con rifle en Filadelfia Pensilvania dejó
cinco muertos y varios heridos en las
horas previas había ocurrido en
Baltimore Maryland y en forwards Texas
allí un evento al aire libre y un
festival dejaron dos y tres víctimas
mortales respectivamente así como más de
una treintena de heridos muchos de ellos
menores
este país necesita re examinar su
conciencia Y averiguar Cómo sacar las
armas de las personas peligrosas una
persona que camina por una calle de la
ciudad con un rifle y dispara al azar a
personas mientras usa un chaleco
antibalas es una situación vergonzosa
pero demasiado común en Estados Unidos
mientras la nación continúa inmersa en
una oleada imparable de violencia Armada
con más de 340 tiroteos masivos en lo
ocurrido del año el presidente
Joe biden aprovechó para pedir una mayor
regulación el congreso debe intensificar
sus acciones a probar leyes de control
de armas pasadas en el sentido común
para proteger a nuestros niños y
profesores armar a los maestros no es la
respuesta
al margen de las conmemoraciones
protocolarias en Highland Park Illinois
hubo recuerdo para las víctimas del
tiroteo masivo que se saldó con la vida
de siete personas y dejó a otras 36
heridas hace un año
no necesitamos la fecha o el feriado
para recordarnos lo que pasó vivimos con
eso todos los días cada uno de nosotros
incluso a medida que el mundo avanza la
pérdida Y el dolor nunca nos abandonarán
Pero al final del día como cada cuatro
de Julio Volvió el Patriotismo sobre el
cielo de la capital con el clásico
despliegue de fuegos artificiales y
actuaciones musicales
[Música]